こんしゅうのざっくばらん
炎上騒ぎについて
せんしゅう、私がnoteに投稿した記事が、いわゆる「炎上」を起こしました。
とある記事を紹介する紹介記事だったのですが、紹介された人が不満を表明し、それに目をつけた「ネットの住民」たちがいっせいに私を攻撃し始めたのです。
炎上騒ぎは初めてではないので、放置をしていたのですが、著作権に関して誤解している人が多いので、「紹介記事を書くことは著作権違反なのか」という記事を書いて私の立場を明確にしました。
詳しくはその記事に書きましたが、著作権で守られているのは「文章や表現」であり、情報やアイデアそのものは著作権の保護対象ではなく、著作権法上の引用の要件を満たす形で紹介・論評することは認められている、というのが私の理解です。
とはいえ、noteの記事はエーアイに書かせているため、元の記事を書いた著者に対するリスペクトが不足しており、かつ、載せた情報量が多すぎたため、それが今回の炎上に結びついたと反省しています。
これは私が、エーアイに与えてたプロンプト、正確にはスキルの問題なので、より多くのリスペクトを元の記事に与えながら、最低限必要な情報以上は載せない「要約・紹介」にとどめるように微調整を与えているところです。
ちなみに、私がメルマガを始めた一番の理由は、ブログの記事が起こす炎上に疲れたからです。
noteでの執筆を加速した途端にこんな風に炎上してしまうと、noteを道具として使うことが果たして正しい戦略なのかどうかは疑問に思えてしまいますが、とりあえずは続けてみようと思います。
決済のStripeは、なぜ「エーアイの振り分け役」に1兆円を払うのか？
せんしゅう、決済サービスを提供するStripeが、エーアイモデルの「振り分け役」をしているOpenRouterを七十億ドル、約1兆円超で買収することで合意したという報道がありました。
[EN]Stripe will reportedly acquire AI gateway startup OpenRouter for $7B+[/EN]
とても興味深い話なので、解説します。
Stripeは、2010年にアイルランド出身のPatrick CollisonとJohn Collisonの兄弟が、当時それぞれ21歳と19歳で創業した、アメリカの決済インフラの会社です。
ネットショップやアプリが「クレジットカードで支払う」画面を自前で作ろうとすると、複数のカード会社との契約、不正利用の検知、各国の規制対応と、膨大な手間がかかります。
Stripeは、その面倒をすべて引き受け、数行のプログラムを組み込むだけで決済が使えるようにしました。
開発者にとっての使いやすさを最優先に設計されたことが、同社が急成長した最大の理由で、今やオンライン決済のデファクト・スタンダードと言っても良いポジションにある会社です。
現在のStripeは、単なる「カード決済の代行屋」ではありません。
月額課金、つまりサブスクリプションの管理、マーケットプレイス型サービスでの売上の分配、シンギュラリティ・ソサエティで提供している「おもちかえり.com」は、これを活用しています。
請求書の発行、法人設立の代行、不正検知まで扱う総合的な金融インフラになっています。
顧客にはアマゾン、Ford、オープンエーアイなどが名を連ねています。
同社の2025年の年次レターによると、Stripe上で扱われた取引総額は一兆九千億ドル、約290兆円で、前年比34パーセント増。
これは世界のジーディーピーのおよそ1.6パーセントに相当するきぼです。
会社は黒字で、その利益を製品開発と買収に振り向けている、としています。
Stripeはまだ株式を公開していませんが、2026年2月、同社は従業員や元従業員が持ち株を現金化できるようにする「テンダーオファー」、つまり会社側が自社株を買い取る仕組みを実施し、そこでの評価額は千五百九十億ドル、約24兆円でした。
前年の千六十七億ドルから大幅な上昇です。
上場の予定について共同創業者のJohn Collison氏はことし1月、Bloombergの取材に「急いではいない」と答えており、正式な上場申請も出ていません。
市場関係者の見方としては2027年以降が本命とされています。
上場を急がない理由として挙げられるのは、すでに黒字で二十二億ドルきぼのフリーキャッシュフローがあり資金調達の必要が薄いこと、そしてテンダーオファーによって従業員や投資家に現金化の機会を定期的に提供できていることです。
いっぽうのOpenRouterは、2023年に創業したばかりの会社で、エーアイゲートウェイ、つまりエーアイの窓口と呼ばれるサービスを提供しています。
オープンエーアイ、アンソロピック、グーグル、メタ、DeepSeekなど各社が出している400種類以上のエーアイモデルを、ひとつの窓口から使えるようにするサービスです。
開発者は自分のプログラムを書き換えることなく、用途と予算に応じてモデルを切り替えられます。
難しい作業には高価で賢いモデル、単純な分類作業には安いモデル、というように使い分けができるわけです。
創業者のAlex Atallah氏は、NFTの最大手マーケットプレイスOpenSeaの共同創業者で、同社のシーティーオーを務めていた人物です。
多数の売り手と買い手の間に立つ「取引の場」を作った経験を持つ人物が、次にエーアイモデルの取引の場を作った、という経歴になります。
Atallah氏は自社を「エーアイ版のStripe」と表現していました。
多様なエーアイモデルへの入り口をひとつにまとめ、特定の会社に縛られる状態、つまりロックインを避けられる、という意味です。
OpenRouterの成長速度は数字にも表れています。
同社の発表によると、利用する開発者は世界で800万人を超え、扱うトークン、つまりエーアイが文章をしょりするときの最小単位の量は、半年で週5兆トークンから週25兆トークンへと5倍に増えました。
年間では1,000兆トークンを超えるペースだとしています。
調査会社Sacraの推計では、年換算の売上は2025年末の約千九百万ドルから、2026年3月には約五千万ドルに達しています。
資金調達の経緯も急展開でした。
2025年にAndreessen HorowitzとMenlo Venturesが主導する形でシードとシリーズAを合わせて四千万ドルを調達。
そして2026年5月には、Alphabet傘下の投資会社CapitalGが主導するシリーズBで一億千三百万ドルを調達し、このときの評価額が十三億ドルでした。
この回にはエヌビディアの投資部門NVentures、ServiceNow、MongoDB、Snowflake、Databricksといった企業の投資部門も参加しています。
そのわずか3か月後に出てきたのが、今回の買収報道です。
まずThe Wall Street Journalが7月下旬、Stripeが百億ドルきぼでOpenRouterの買収を交渉中だと報じました。
続いて8月16日、Bloombergが「七十億ドル超で買収を固めた」と報道し、TechCrunchなどが追随しています。
5月の十三億ドルから見れば、3か月で約5倍の値付けです。
ただし、両社とも正式な発表はしておらず、StripeはTechCrunchの取材に対して「噂や憶測にはコメントしない」と答えています。
現時点では報道ベースの、未確認の情報です。
直感的には、決済会社がなぜ エーアイ ベンチャーを買収するのか分かりにくいと思います。
しかし OpenRouter が実際にやっていることを分解すると、話は違って見えてきます。
多数の提供者と多数の利用者の間に立ち、使った分だけを細かく計量し、少額の課金を大量に集計し、集めたお金を提供者ごとに分配する。
これは Stripe が15年にわたってやってきたことそのものです。
相手がカードの加盟店から エーアイ モデルの提供者に変わっただけで、仕組みの骨格は同じなのです。
Atallah 氏が自社を「エーアイ版の Stripe」と呼んでいたのは、気の利いた比喩ではなく、業務内容のそのままの説明だったことになります。
しかも両社が向き合っている相手は、どちらも「自分のサービスに機能を組み込みたい開発者」で、顧客層はほぼ完全に重なっています。
OpenRouterが果たそうとしているもう一つの重要な使命は、エーアイを少数の企業による寡占状態から、オープンウェイトなモデルも交えた過当競争によりコモディティ化することにあります。
普段は安価なモデルを使いながら、必要に応じて高価なモデルを使うことを可能にする。
値段・スピード・信頼性をリアルタイムに監視してユーザーにとって最適なエーアイサービスを自動的に選んでくれる。
そんな「開発者寄り」なサービスです。
今回の買収は、Stripeが決済エーピーアイの会社から、エーアイエージェント時代の経済活動を支えるmetering、billing、routing、settlementのインフラ会社になろうとしている、と解釈しても良いと思います。
ばいぶコーディングと大規模リファクタリング
ソフトウェア作りをしていると、ある程度のじっそうが進んだ段階で、スタートした時点の設計よりも「より良い設計」を思いつく、発見することがしばしばあります。
必ずしも当初のせっけいが悪かったわけではなく、じっそうする過程で新しく見えてくるものも多々あるので、仕方がありません。
どんな優秀なエンジニアでも、当初から完璧なせっけいをすることは不可能なのです。
なので、「設計から間違っているかも知れない」という可能性も想定しながら、手早く動くものを作り上げ、そこまで辿り着いて初めて見えてきた知見を設計に反映することがたいせつです。
せっけいの変更度合いによっては、そこまでに作ったソフトウェアの大半を捨てて作り直さなければならないこと、大規模リファクタリング、動作はそのままに、ソフトウェアの中身の作りを根本から作り直すことがありますが、それを嫌がっていては良いソフトウェアは作れません。
大規模リファクタリングは、開発者の精神的な痛み、開発コストの上昇、スケジュールの遅延、テストのやり直しなどの「大きな痛み」を伴うため、なんとか回避しようとしがちですが、これは賢明ではありません。
そもそも痛みの大きさは、そこまでにどれだけ作り込んでしまったかで決まります。
設計に時間と手間をかけてしまうと、「あれだけコストをかけて作った設計だから間違っているわけがない」という心理的バイアスが働き、せっけいの間違いを素直に認めずにプロジェクトを進め、泥沼にハマってしまう可能性が高くなります。
プロジェクトの初期の段階では、設計・じっそうの両方を可能な限り手早く行うことにより、いわゆる「サンクコスト」、つまり埋没費用、すでに使ってしまい、もう取り戻せない時間やお金を下げるべきなのです。
私にとってはこれが当たり前の開発手法で、他の人にも勧めて来たのですが、実際にこの開発手法を採用してくれる人はごく稀でした。
多くのエンジニアにとって「自分が書いたコードを捨てる」ことは苦痛だし、締切が迫らないとなかなか本気になれないからです。
しかし、ばいぶコーディング、つまりエーアイにコードを書かせることが可能になった今、もう言い訳はできません。
エーアイは自分が書いたコードを捨てられても落ち込むことはないし、締切に関係なく、全力で仕事をしてくれるからです。
なので、さいしょに頭に浮かんだ設計で、とりあえずエーアイにコードを書かせてみるのは十分にアリだと思います。
頭に複数のアプローチが浮かんだのなら、それぞれ別のエーアイエージェント、つまり人間の指示を受けて自分で作業を進めるエーアイにコードを書かせ、うまく動いたものだけを採用するという贅沢な開発スタイルさえ可能です。
もちろん、エーアイはせっけいの相談にも乗ってくれるので、アイデアを投げかけて一緒にせっけいするのも良い方法ですが、じっそうを始めないと見えてこないことは常にあるので、開発しながら「そもそもこの設計で良かったのだろうか」と吟味を続けることがたいせつです。
「コードを猛烈な勢いで書いてくれるエーアイ」が身近なものになったからこそ可能になった、「作っては壊す」スタイルのものづくり、是非とも試してみてください。
エーアイ時代には、コードそのものへの執着を捨てる必要があります。
価値があるのはコードではなく、「何を作るべきか」という設計思想と、動くものから得た知見です。
トラフィック理論とソブリンエーアイ
スーパーのレジに並ぶと、必ず「隣の列のほうが速く進む」という理不尽を味わいます。
いっぽう、銀行や空港のカウンターでは、列を一本にまとめて、空いた窓口へ先頭の人から順に進んでもらう方式が使われています。
あの一本の列は、公平で気分が良いというだけの話ではありません。
まったく同じ人数の窓口を使って、行列そのものを劇的に短くする仕掛けなのです。
私はNTTにいた頃にトラフィック理論、つまり待ち行列理論、窓口と行列の関係を数学で扱う学問を勉強しましたが、いちばん印象に残ったのがこの話でした。
列を分けてしまうと、「空いている窓口があるのに、別の列で人が待っている」という無駄な瞬間が必ず生まれます。
列を一本にすれば、これは原理的に起こりません。
窓口が4つあってどれもかなり忙しい、という状況で計算すると、列を分けた場合の待ち人数は、一本にまとめた場合の4倍から5倍にもなります。
設備も人員もまったく同じなのに、です。
さらに面白いのは、この効果が規模とともに大きくなることです。
窓口が10個の設備は、客をほとんど待たせずに使える能力が全体の45パーセント程度しかありませんが、100個なら84パーセント、1000個なら97パーセントまで使い切れます。
裏返して言えば、ある量の仕事をこなすのに、1箇所にまとめれば窓口は100個で足りるのに、10箇所に分けて持たせると160個必要になります。
分けるだけで、6割も多くの設備が要るわけです。
ここで視点を逆にすると、面白いことに気づきます。
窓口そのものを売る業者にとっては、世の中の行列が一本にまとまっていない方が、はるかに商売になります。
そしてエヌビディアが各国政府に熱心に売り込んでいる「ソブリンエーアイ」、つまり主権エーアイ、自国の国境の中に、自国のためのエーアイ計算基盤を持つという考え方は、まさにこれに当たります。
世界全体で束ねれば100個で足りる計算設備が、国ごとに分けて持たせれば160個売れます。
しかも国という分け方は、効率の観点からは最悪の分け方です。
ひとつの国の利用者は同じ時間帯に集中するので、じゅようの山が均されません。
世界全体で束ねていれば、アジアが眠っている間にアメリカが使う、という形で山が消えるはずのものです。
そして決定的なのは、この分割がデータ保護や安全保障を理由に法律で固定されるため、後から誰も束ね直せないこと。
ただ、エヌビディアにとっての本当の旨味は、売れる台数が増えることよりも、買い手の顔ぶれが変わることかもしれません。
現状は、売上の大半が数社の巨大IT企業に集中します。
値切る力が強く、しかもグーグルやアマゾンのように自社製のエーアイチップを作り始めています。
ソブリンエーアイが広がれば、買い手は数十の政府に分散します。
価格交渉力は桁違いに弱まります。
政府の予算は採算ではなく政治判断です。
稼働率が低くても「戦略的な備え」と呼ばれ、誰も問題にしません。
そして最近になって、パランティアが「企業もオープンウェイト、つまり重みが公開されたモデル、手元にダウンロードして自社のサーバーで動かせるエーアイを使って、自社専用のエーアイ基盤を持つべきだ」と主張し始めました。
分割の単位が、国から企業へと一段細かくなるわけです。
世界が数十に割れるのと、数千、数万に割れるのとでは、無駄の量が違います。
企業の自社サーバーは利用者が単一の時間帯、しかも平日の昼間に集中するので、夜間も週末もほぼ遊んでいます。
実際、企業が自前で持つエーアイ用サーバーの稼働率は2〜3割という話をよく聞きます。
ここで注目すべきは、オープンウェイトの役割です。
最先端の商用エーアイは社内に置けませんが、公開されたモデルなら置けます。
つまりオープンウェイトこそが、企業単位の分割を技術的に可能にした条件なのです。
無料で公開されたモデルは、一見すると業界の既得権を壊す民主化の動きに見えますが、計算機を売る側から見れば、じゅようを細かく砕いてくれるありがたい存在ということになります。
さらに見逃せないのが、この流れがASIC、つまりエーシック、特定の用途だけに特化して設計された専用チップの出番を奪ってしまうことです。
グーグルのティーピーユーやアマゾンのTrainiumのような専用チップは、一つ設計して量産にこぎつけるまでに数百億円きぼの開発費となんねんもの歳月がかかります。
それが成り立つのは、自社の中に膨大なじゅようがあって、開発費を薄く広く分散できるからです。
しかもグーグルはティーピーユーを外部に売りません。
自社クラウドの競争力そのものだからです。
ここに、企業単位に砕かれたじゅようを並べてみてください。
一社分のじゅようでは専用チップを起こす規模に遠く及ばず、かといって既製の専用チップを買ってくることもできません。
残る選択肢は、誰でも買える市販のチップ、つまりエヌビディアだけになります。
分割は、エヌビディアにとって売れる台数を増やすだけでなく、競合の選択肢そのものを消してしまうのです。
全体を眺めると、これは「行列を一本にまとめたい側」と「砕きたい側」の戦争だと言えます。
まとめたい側は、巨大IT企業と最先端エーアイの開発企業です。
全世界のじゅようを一本の行列に集めて効率の果実を独占し、いずれは自社製チップでエヌビディアを締め上げたい。
砕きたい側は、エヌビディアとパランティア、そしてオープンウェイトの陣営です。
行列を国へ、企業へ、さらには手元の端末へと砕き続けたいのです。
エヌビディアにとっての最大の脅威はAMDではなく、買い手がほんの数社に集約してしまうことなので、主権エーアイも企業内エーアイも端末内エーアイも、すべて一貫した防衛戦になっているわけです。
もっとも、この筋書きが崩れる目は二つあります。
稼働率が2割の設備はどう計算しても採算が合わないので、いずれ企業の財務責任者が気づくこと。
そして、公開されたモデルが小型化するほど、売れるのは最高級品ではなく中位の製品になり、台数は増えても利益率は下がっていくこと。
各国が国営航空会社を競って持った時代に、いちばん儲けたのはボーイングとエアバスでした。
「自分たちのデータを、自分たちの手元で」という主張自体は、まぎれもない正論です。
しかし正論であることと、社会全体として膨大な無駄が生まれることは、まったく矛盾なく両立してしまうのです。
私の目に留まった記事
せんしゅうから、noteにエーアイによる要約を書き、ここに私の意見を書く、というスタイルを試しています。
歓迎してくれている読者と、前のままの方が良いと指摘する読者が半々ぐらいなので、徐々に良いバランスを見つけたいと考えています。
まずは、noteの記事を開かなくても大まかな内容が分かる形で書いてみます。
エーアイがエーアイを改良する「暴走」は、もう始まっているのか？
エーアイ自身が次世代のエーアイを作り始め、人間を置いてきぼりにして爆発的な進化を遂げてしまうことを「シンギュラリティ」と呼びますが、どんな条件が整えばそれが起こるのかを数式を交えて真面目に議論している論文です。
この論文が素晴らしいのは、計算能力など外部要因を除くために、爆発的な進化を遂げる状態、つまりアールエスアイ、再帰的自己改善を「研究者やコンピュータを増やさなくても、エーアイの進歩がひとりでに速くなっていく状態」と明確に定義した上で、「エーアイの能力を測るEpoch Capabilities Indexが1点上がるごとに、エーアイ研究の生産性が15パーセント以上上がるなら、自己持続的な加速が始まる」と、定性的に予想している点です。
現時点では、楽観的に見積もっても9パーセント程度なので、まだ自己持続的な加速の中にはいないとこの論文は結論付けていますが、最先端のエーアイモデルを使ってソフトウェアを作っている当事者としては、それほど遠くない未来に「シンギュラリティ」と呼べる状態に突入しても不思議はないと感じています。
エーアイが生んだ価値は、誰のものになるのか？
パランティアのシーイーオー、アレックス・カープ氏のCNBCインタビューの紹介で、さいきんの彼の主張を理解するには良い記事です。
彼の主張を簡単にまとめると、以下のようなものです。
フロンティア・ラボ、つまりアンソロピックやオープンエーアイのエーアイサービスを使っていると、自分たちのノウハウが彼らに吸い取られてしまいます。
そのノウハウを利用して、彼らは顧客のビジネスを奪いにくるのです。
それを避けるにはオープンウェイトなモデルを使い、その上に独自のエーアイエージェントを持つべきです。
国も企業も、フロンティア・ラボに頼らない「エーアイ主権」、つまりソブリンエーアイを自分自身で握るべきです。
エーアイ主権とは、自国・自社のコントロール下にあるデータ・モデル・計算資源等のエーアイ基盤ということです。
もちろんこれは、顧客に対してエーアイコンサルティングを提供するパランティアのポジション・トークでもあるので、そこは意識しておくべきです。
しかし、さいきんはエヌビディアもソブリンエーアイの重要性を主張しており、ここからしばらくは、国家と企業、それぞれのレベルでのソブリンエーアイの議論が盛んになることは確実なので、彼の主張を一通り頭に入れておくと、議論についていけると思います。
住宅の「使われていない電力容量」を集めて、エーアイデータセンターにできるのか？
一般住宅の電力容量を借りて分散型のエーアイデータセンターを構築するというとても興味深いアプローチの紹介です。
この事業をスタートしたSPANは、住宅用のスマート分電盤を提供している会社ですが、その延長として、一般家庭にエヌビディアの最新のジーピーユーを16個搭載した「XFRAノード」と呼ばれる屋外設置型のエーアイサーバーを置き、それらをネットワークで繋いで分散型のエーアイデータセンターサービスとして提供しようというアイデアです。
現在、エーアイデータセンターの設置の一番のボトルネックは電力や冷却水の確保であり、その問題を解決する手法として、提案されているそうです。
電源網への負荷が増えることには変わらないので、本質的な解決にはなっていませんが、電力会社との契約や地方自治体からの許可を回避することはできそうです。
本来ならば、Teslaがこのビジネスをやるべきだと思います。
太陽光パネル、プラス蓄電池ビジネスとの整合性も良いし、Teslaは自動車向けにかいはつした高性能なヒートポンプの制御技術があります。
ロボタクシーやオプティマスと比べるとプライオリティは低いとは思いますが、A5チップの量産がスタートした段階で、Powerwall、つまり蓄電池にA5チップを搭載して、余った電力ですいろんを分散型で行う、ぐらいのことはやっても不思議はありません。
Cursorはギットハブを置き換えようとしているのか？
SpaceXとxAIに買収されたばかりのCursorが、マイクロソフトのGithubに相当するOriginというサービスをローンチしたことを紹介する記事です。
Git、つまりギットはソフトウェア・エンジニアたちにとっては必須なソースコードの管理ソフトですが、それをサービス化した、Githubは特にオープンソース業界ではデファクト・スタンダードになっています。
私も毎日のように使っています。
エーアイを活用した開発環境を提供するCursorは、Githubが「コードが書けるエーアイ」が誕生する前に設計されたものであることに目をつけ、「エーアイから操作しやすい」ことを重視してOriginを作ったそうです。
Cursorが何を狙ってこのサービスを立ち上げたのか明確ではありませんが、開発者向けの環境を最適な形で、それもフルスタックで提供したいというのもあるでしょうし、xAIの学習データとして活用の可能性も十分にあります。
いずれにせよ、xAIがオープンエーアイとアンソロピックの二強に挑む上で、Cursorがとても重要な役割を果たすことは見えているので、こんごは、xAI、プラスCursorが提供する開発環境に注目して行きたいと思います。
AirPodsにカメラが載る日：アップルはイヤホンを「Siriの目」にしようとしているのか？
カメラ付きのAirPodsをアップルが開発していることを報じる、Patently Appleのエックスへの投稿の紹介です。
さいしょに報じたのはThe Informationですが、アップルからリークされた映像に、AirPodsを装着したユーザーが目の前のものについて、Siri、つまりアップルのエーアイアシスタントに質問している様子が描かれていたそうです。
公式な発表ではありません。
ウェアラブルなエーアイアシスタントに関しては、メタがスマートグラスを発売し、グーグルもハードウェア・メーカーとの提携を発表していますが、アップルがこのしじょうに出てくることは必然です。
スマートグラスではなく、AirPodsという点はとてもアップルらしく、まずはiPhoneのアクセサリとして、ディスプレイのない形でしじょうに参入するのは理にかなっています。
ちなみに、アップルは、Magnificent7、つまりジーエーエフエーエム、プラスエヌビディア、プラスTeslaの中で唯一、巨大なエーアイデータセンターへの投資には慎重で、投資家の意見も分かれていますが、私はアップルの株主の一人としては、今の立ち位置は悪くないと感じています。
アップルが力を入れるべきなのは、デバイス上での推論であり、エーアイアシスタントに関しても、基本的にはデバイス上で画像認識・音声認識をするのがプライバシーを重視したアップルのやり方として正しいのです。
そこさえしっかりと作り込めば、後発でもメタやグーグルに勝てる可能性は十分にあると私は期待しています。
エーアイが設計した「一人ひとり違うがんワクチン」は、本当に効いたのか？
新型コロナ禍の時期にエムアールエヌエーワクチンで注目を浴びたModernaが、今度はエーアイを活用して、特定の癌患者の癌をピンポイントで攻撃するエムアールエヌエーワクチンを開発し、フェーズ3にまでたどり着いたことを報告する記事です。
癌は細胞が突然変異によって異常増殖することですが、この手法は、ディーエヌエー分析により突然変異したディーエヌエーを突き止め、癌細胞をピンポイントで攻撃するエムアールエヌエーワクチンを独自のエーアイを活用してオンデマンドで作り出して患者に投与するものです。
通常の医薬品と違って、患者の特定の癌細胞だけを攻撃するワクチンなので、効果的なだけでなく、副作用も少ないことが期待されていますが、一人一人に異なるワクチンを作って与える点が特徴です。
それがフェーズ3でも良好な結果を出したというのは大きな前進です。
このニュースを受けて、Modernaの株は大きく上昇しました。
私は、新型コロナの時期にModernaのことを知り、癌ワクチンに期待して株を少し購入しましたが、その後の動きが全くないので、手放してしまいました。
もう少し我慢して持ち続けておくべきでした。
ひとがたロボットは「研究者のおもちゃ」から抜け出せるのか？
上海しじょうにじょうじょうする、中国のロボットベンチャー、Unitree、つまりユニツリーの紹介記事です。
米国のライバル、TeslaやFigureが、頭脳、つまりソフトウェア、プラスエーアイも含めた完成品のかいはつを進めているのに対し、Unitreeは、誰でもソフトウェアをインストールできるオープンな形で、可能な限り安価な価格でハードウェアを提供することにより、世界中の研究者たちに幅広く受け入れられました。
こんごは、Unitree自身も頭脳の開発に力を入れるそうですが、そこが「研究者のおもちゃ」から脱却できるかどうかを決める鍵になります。
ちなみに、TeslaやFigureは、関節を動かすために、精度を重視して高価でギア比の高い「減速機」、つまりハーモニックドライブを使っていますが、Unitreeは、安価でギア比の低い「準ダイレクトドライブ」、つまりキューディーディーを採用しています。
ギア比が低いということは、外部からのショックを吸収しやすいことを意味し、バク転などをしてもギアが壊れないのは、それが理由です。
しかし、その分、モーターはより多くの力を出す必要があり、長時間の運用は、つまり発する熱のために、難しいとされています。
逆にギア比の高い減速機は、ショックに弱く、高価ですが、小さなモーターで大きな力を出すことができるし、動きも正確で、長時間の運用が可能です。
この違いは、Unitreeが研究やエンターテイメントしじょうで先行し、TeslaやFigureは、まずは工場での運用にプライオリティを置いて開発していることとも深く関連しているので、頭の片隅にでも覚えておくと良いと思います。
質問コーナー
【質問】
今回の自動運転のお話、とても興味深かったです。
ロボタクシーではなく「いっぱんの乗用車やトラックへの自動運転搭載」が大きなしじょうになるとした場合、中島さんがこんご特に注目されている企業はありますか？
エヌビディアのような半導体だけでなく、センサーやソフトウェアなども含めて「自動運転の普及で最も恩恵を受けそうな企業」があれば、ぜひお聞きしたいです。
《回答》
センサーに関しては、ライダー関連の企業の株が一時期注目を集めましたが、Teslaがカメラのみのアプローチで高度な自動運転が十分に可能であることを示しているので、こんごは難しいと思います。
その意味では、画像センサーで圧倒的なシェアを持つソニーは良いポジションにあると思います。
TeslaもHW4からは採用しているという情報もあるし、公式発表は見つかりませんでしたが、HW3からHW4にアップグレードする際には、カメラもアップグレードする必要があるとされています。
ひとがたロボットにも複数のカメラが必要です。
注として、私は、ソニーの株は持っていません。
【質問】
私は自社で生成エーアイの活用促進・開発体制構築に関わっています。
社内では標準としてClaudeを採用していますが、開発者からは「他のツールも状況に応じて柔軟に使いたい」「エルエルエムごとに得意・不得意があるので、複数モデルの回答を比較しながらかいはつしたほうが品質が上がる」という要望も出ています。
いっぽうで企業として秘匿情報を扱う以上、利用ツールを分散させるとガバナンス、つまりアクセス管理・情報漏洩対策・コスト管理の統制が難しくなるという課題もあります。
こうした中で、私自身は「日進月歩で変化が速い今の環境では、一つのソリューションに固めて開発に集中する方が、目先の性能競争に一喜一憂せず生産性を上げられるのではないか」と考えています。
複数エルエルエムを併用するかいはつが一定品質を上げる面があることは理解していますが、たとえば月次で乗り換えるような運用よりも、一定期間は一つに絞り込んだほうがそのエーアイの活用方法の習熟などもすすみ結局は生産性が高いのでは、という仮説です。
現場からはオープンエーアイのCodexや最近話題のKimiといったソリューションなどがClaudeの性能を超えた、価格が下がった、などの話題が出るたびにそういった議論が少なからず起こります。
現状では全社的にそのような戦略を取るのはリスクがあると考えているため、とある開発者グループの中でのみ許容して利用させるような方針を考えてはおります。
そこで伺いたいのは、開発者として単一ソリューションに集中する開発スタイルと、複数エルエルエムを併用・比較する開発スタイル、どちらがより良い選択だとお考えでしょうか？
実際の開発現場感覚として、モデルの入れ替わりの速さ、性能の上下・新モデル登場もあるなかで、統制を優先して一つに固定する戦略にどの程度のリスク・機会損失を生むとおもわれますか？
仮に中島さんが私のような立場であればどのような戦略をとられるでしょうか？
ご意見をいただけますと幸いです。
よろしくお願いいたします。
《回答》
当事者目線で言うと、エーアイモデル、つまりClaude、ジーピーティー、Geminiそのものよりも、その周りのハーネス、つまりClaude Code、Codex、Antigravityが重要で、「エーアイモデルは切り替えるのは簡単だけど、ハーネスの切り替えは面倒」と言うのが正直なところです。
私は、日々のコーディングは95パーセント以上Claude Codeで行なっていますが、時々CodexやAntigravityを意図的に使うことにより、そちらにも慣れておくようにしています。
とはいえ、スキルなどは、Claude Code向けのものが蓄積して行くので、実際の切り替えは簡単ではないと思います。
この回答を書いていて思いましたが、オープンソースなハーネスで優秀なものがあれば、エーアイモデルはOpenRouterで繋いで、必要に応じてダイナミックに切り替えるのも悪くないと思いました。
ただし、従量課金になるため、私のように、アンソロピックのMaxプランのような使い放題の恩恵を受けている人には選び難い選択肢です。
【質問】
日本におけるデータセンター建設の是非について質問です。
エーアイじゅようの拡大に伴い、日本国内でのデータセンター建設が年々増加しています。
しかし、外資系企業、特に不動産企業による日本の土地取得が進むことには、以下のようなデメリットがあると考えています。
大規模施設の乱立による日本の景観の喪失
電力じゅようの急増による電気料金の高騰
製造業をはじめとする他産業との電力の奪い合い
再エネきょうきゅうが追いつかない場合、火力発電への依存が続き、脱炭素化と逆行する環境負荷の増大
有事における標的化リスク、つまりミサイル攻撃や、データセンター周辺での物理的な争奪・破壊工作
雇用効果の限定性。
建設時の雇用は生まれるが、運用フェーズの雇用は1棟あたり数十人程度にとどまる
これらのデメリットを踏まえてもなお、日本でデータセンター建設を進めるメリットはあると思いますか？
あるとすれば、それは上記のリスクを上回るものでしょうか。
ご意見をお聞かせください。
《回答》
とても重要な話ですが、まずは電力の問題を解決するところから始める必要があると思います。
輸入した化石燃料に頼っている限り「ソブリンエーアイ」、つまりエーアイ主権とは程遠い状況です。
原発政策は破綻しているし、風力・太陽光・地熱・水力のどれもが、周辺環境との課題を抱えています。
発送電の分離が進んでいないのも大きな欠点です。
核融合が近いうちに実用化されれば話は別ですが。
その意味では、これから建てるあらゆる建物の屋根と壁を一体型の太陽光パネルにすることを義務化し、それを使って分散型のエーアイデータセンターを作るような過激な政策を取らない限りは、「米国頼り」な状況からは脱せないと思います。
そもそも、ここまで食料の自給率が低い日本が「ソブリンエーアイ」を叫んだところで意味がないとも言えますが。
【質問】
現在、カナダの大学、政治学部を卒業後、現地の海運会社で営業職をしております。
将来的に製造業である家業を継ぐ予定で、キャリアの選択肢として北米エムビーエーへの進学に興味を持っています。
しかし、エーアイによる産業革命が急速に進む中で、20代の貴重な2年間と資金を エムビーエー に費やすことの真の価値について考え込んでしまいます。
変化の激しいこの時代において、将来経営者となる人間が今エムビーエーで学ぶことの意義や、あるいはそれ以上に優先すべき学びについて、中島さんのご意見をお聞かせいただけたら嬉しいです。
よろしくお願いいたします。
《回答》
これは難しい質問ですね。
一般的な答えとしては、エムビーエーは、ネットワーク、ブランド、そして意思決定の枠組みを学ぶ場だと言えます。
特にトップスクールの場合、同期や教授のネットワークは、その後のキャリアの大きな資産になります。
しかし、あなたの場合は少し違うと思います。
家業を継ぐということは、その業界に関する深い知識と経験が何より重要だからです。
製造業の経営者に必要なのは、経営学の一般的な知識というより、サプライチェーン、ものづくりのプロセス、顧客との関係、競争環境を具体的に理解していることなのです。
海運会社での営業経験は、実は非常に貴重です。
そこで得られるのは、実際のビジネスの流れ、業界の課題、取引先との付き合い方といった、どのエムビーエーのカリキュラムにも勝る学びです。
その経験を積み重ねながら、あなたの家業について思索を深める。
その中で「何が足りないのか」が見えたとき、初めてエムビーエーの価値が出てくるのだと思います。
エーアイが経営の一部を自動化してくれるようになる時代だからこそ、人間の経営者に求められるのは、業界知識と人的ネットワークです。
もしエムビーエーに行くなら、2年間のインターンシップも含めて、できるだけビジネス経験を積む方向で選べば良いでしょう。
タイトル：週刊Life is beautiful ２０２６年８月２５日号：決済のStripeは、なぜ「AIの振り分け役」に1兆円を払うのか？
、バイブコーディングと大規模リファクタリング、トラフィック理論とソブリンAI（パート2/2）
実際に米国でエムビーエーを取得した経験から言うと、エムビーエーの授業の中で「実質的な価値」を持つのは、Corporate FinanceとFinancial Accountingのみです。
Micro/Macro Economicsも基礎知識としては重要です。
なので、効率を目指すのであれば、その四つの科目を半年ぐらいかけてみっちりと勉強すれば十分です。
今ならオンラインコースも複数あるので、留学しなくても学べます。
日本の学校でも学べると思いますが、英語で勉強することを強くお勧めします。
もちろん、米国でエムビーエーを取れば肩書きにはなるし、ネットワークもできるので、プラスアルファのメリットもありますが、時間とコストを考えれば、無理してまで取得する必要はないと思います。
それでは、読者からのご質問にお答えしていきます。
アラフォー転職における「スペシャリスト vs マネジメント」の年収限界についてのご質問です。
フィンテック系の企業に勤めており、現在転職活動を行っていますが、「アラフォーであればマネジメント経験がある方が有利」という風潮を感じています。
一方で、自分自身は組織管理よりも、一匹狼として専門スキルを尖らせて成果を出していきたい想いがあります。
これまでもそうでした。
これからの時代、サラリーマンとして高い年収を目指す場合、マネジメントを避けて専門性だけで生き残る、つまり高年収を得ることは可能でしょうか。
それとも、サラリーマンという構造上、マネジメント経験は避けて通れない領域だとお考えでしょうか。
中島さんから見て、これからの時代における個人のキャリア戦略のあり方についてご意見をいただけますと幸いです。
という質問ですね。
私は一匹狼タイプなので、大きくバイアスがかかっているとは思いますが、これだけ変化の大きな時代なので、中途半端に空気を読んでキャリアパスを築くよりは、自分がとくいなこと、夢中になれることに集中すべきだと思います。
私の経験から言えば、「他の人にとって苦行と思えるようなことを楽しんでできる職」を見つけることができれば、充実した人生を送れるし、成功する可能性も高くなります。
続いて、特別支援学校で教員をしている読者からのご報告です。
Claudeにお願いしてゲームを五十個ほど作りました。
面白くなかった十個はボツにしました。
面白いかどうかの判断、うちの生徒ができるかどうかの調整はエーアイにはできません。
これがまさにエーアイありきの時代に人間がやるべきことなんじゃないかな、と実感したのでご報告します。
プログラミングは分かりませんが、エーアイに作ってもらったゲームや教育アプリが百五十個ほどになりました。
という報告をいただきました。
いくつか試させてもらいましたが、素晴らしいと思います。
「ソフトウェアの開発コストが限りなくゼロに近づいた時代」だからこそ可能になった典型のようなアプリ群ですね。
こんな先生がいる学校が羨ましいと感じました。
ご指摘の通り、「何を作るべきか」「何が面白いか」の判断は人間の役割ですが、それは突き詰めて考えれば「何が大切か」「子どもたちにどんな価値を提供したいか」という価値観の話です。
エーアイは優秀なエンジニアにますます似てきましたが、根本的に違うのは「価値観の欠如」です。
次のご質問です。
先日は、メルマガ制作における「執筆準備」と「執筆そのもの」の線引きについてご回答いただき、ありがとうございました。
どのトピック・記事を書くかを決め、記事やコメントもご自身で書かれていると知り、エーアイの活用が進む中でも、中島様ご自身の言葉をメルマガを通じて読み続けられることを、うれしく思います。
以前、エーアイに実装を任せる際には、エーアイが持ち合わせていない「何が大切なのか」を人間が先に決めることが重要だとご回答いただいたことも印象に残っています。
こんしゅう号では、共同開発者の有本氏に「Mulmo Terminalを開発者にとってなくてはならないものにして」と依頼したところ、中島様ご自身も当初想定していなかった「とんでもない進化」が起きたと書かれていました。
この「想定していなかった進化」は、どのようなところから生まれたのでしょうか。
有本氏が、中島様やエーアイだけでは持ち得なかった視点や発想を持ち込まれたことが大きかったのでしょうか。
それとも、別の要因があったのでしょうか。
今回のようなご経験を通じて感じておられる、人間の協働者ならではの価値があれば、教えていただけますと幸いです。
という質問ですね。
「想定していなかった進化」のきっかけは、アンスロピックが「-p」オプションを従量課金にするとアナウンスした時に、私が深く考えずに発言した「Terminalをブラウザー上で動かせれば解決するね」という無理難題です。
その無理難題を有本氏が素早く解決し、さらにそれを足がかりに、Mulmo Terminalを「開発者自身にとって、今、必要なツール」に育て上げた点に尽きると思います。
それまで彼はEmacs、私はVS Codeを使って開発してきましたが、複数のエーアイエージェントを使ってコードも見ずに開発するには新しい開発環境が必要だったこと、そして同時に、バイブコーディングによって開発効率が爆あがりしたことが重なり合って、今回の「想定していなかった進化」が起こったのです。
今回に限った話ではありませんが、無理難題は言ってみるものだし、あれこれと考える前に、とにかく手を動かすことが大切だとつくづく思います。
続いて、プログラムというものが全くわからない四十八さいで三児の子どもを持つ父親からのご質問です。
VS Codeと Claude Code を使い、Mulmo Claude にたどり着くことができました。
すごく大変ってわけでもなく、ほとんどが VS Code 上で進めてくれるので一週間ぐらいで Mulmo Claude で自分のログインページを持てました。
最初は、天気予報のページを作ってもらいました。
気象庁のエーピーアイなどを叩きにいってくれて自分用のページができて感動！
その後は、高校受験の子どものために都立高校入試問題の過去問から練習予想問題を作ってもらい、JSON というファイルをフィードバックしてにがてなところやできないところを集計してもらい、次にその対策として新しい問題を作ってもらったりしています。
GitHub にも VS Code からしょりをしてもらいバックアップを作り、GitHub 上にホームページまで公開できるようになっちゃいました。
メルマガでいつもおっしゃっていたことを少しやり始めたら楽しくなっちゃいました。
エーアイアシスタントってすごいですね！
次は、エーアイにエーアイを動かしてもらうことができるようにもっと手を動かしてみます。
という投稿をいただきました。
感想、ありがとうございます！
自分自身で「自分のためのエーアイアシスタント」を育てる感覚を味わっていただけたようで、嬉しい限りです。
ChatGPT に質問を投げかけているだけとは、桁が違うポテンシャルを感じていただけたと思います。
次のご質問です。
中島さんの発信をきっかけに Palantir の長期保有を始めた投資初心者です。
ハイテク・エーアイ銘柄の長期投資で「成長ストーリーの崩壊」が売却基準と言われますが、初心者にはその判断が難しく感じています。
長期投資で「手放すべきサイン、つまりストーリーの終わり」と判断する具体的な指標や変化、顧客数の伸び悩み、競合の出現などがあれば教えていただけますと幸いです。
という質問ですね。
私は「自分が買うべき株」を見出すのには苦労していませんが、「いつ売るか」を見極めるのはとても難しいと感じています。
特に Palantir のように、期待した以上のパフォーマンスを出してくれる企業の株は売る気になれず、自然と長期保有になってしまいます。
具体的な指標のようなものは持ち合わせていませんが、経営陣が語る戦略が共感できなくなったり、その企業が属する業界全体が低迷期に入ったと感じた時に、売却するケースが多いです。
続いて、別の読者からのご質問です。
いつものメルマガでの企業分析やエーアイの話など非エンジニアからすると難しい内容もあるのですがとてもためになっています！
質問なのですが、投資においてアメリカ経済の先行きの不安やエーアイバブルのクラッシュを考えると株式投資に慎重になってしまうのですが、中島さんはそのようなリスクをどのように考えておられますか？
個人的には複数国の通貨、株式、タンジブル資産に分散投資かなと考えております。
という質問ですね。
リスクを取らずに安定した資産形成をしたいのであれば、分散投資をすべきだし、個別株ではなくイーティーエフを購入すべきだと思います。
私の場合は、応援したい企業の株を持つことによりそれを「自分ごとにする」ことに重きを置いているため、どうしても個別株になるし、私自身がどっぷりと使っているテクノロジー株を選ぶことになっています。
分散投資とは程遠いので、クラッシュする時の下がり幅も大きいですが、それも「自分ごとにする」ことの一部だと納得して投資をしています。
別の読者からのご報告です。
あと数年で退職、プログラミングもまともにできない私ですが、中島さんのメルマガにあまりにも Mulmo Claude の話が出てくるので、「これは実際に自分でやってみないと分からない」と思い、挑戦してみました。
ChatGPT に相談しながら、数年前の Mac で Terminal を使い、それだけでも素人には難関でしたが、様々なものをインストールして、ようやく Mulmo Claude を動かすことができました。
算数アプリなどはすぐに作れるのですね！
以前自分で作った、使っているブラウザにしかデータを保存できない読書記録アプリもインポートし、Mulmo Claude 上にまとめることができました。
これからも色々試していきたいです。
これでようやく、メルマガで話されている内容についていけるかもしれません。
やはり、何でも自分でやってみないと、ですね。
いずれ Mulmo Terminal にも挑戦してみたいと思っています。
一つ質問です。
現在、Claude Code は月額二十一点七八ユーロほどのプランを使っていますが、プランによって Mulmo Claude の処理速度に違いは出るのでしょうか？
最後に、なんねんも前に中島さんが NVIDIA について書かれた後、すぐに株を購入しました。
それが今では千七百パーセントにもなり、この点でも中島さんにはとても感謝しています！
というご報告をいただきました。
Claude に関しては、プランによる速度の違いはありません。
Claude はプランごとに、一日・一週間に使えるトークンの上限が定まっており、その上限に達するまでは、どのプランでも同じ速度・同じ能力です。
続いて、別の読者からのご質問です。
年末から中国に出向することになりました。
中島さんだったら中国でどんな事にチャレンジしてみたいですか？
という質問ですね。
出向ということなので、マッチはしないと思いますが、私であれば、エーアイラボ、もしくは、ひとがたロボットを作っているベンチャー企業に飛び込んで、彼らの働き方やエネルギーを直接感じてみたいと思います。
次のご質問です。
X もフォローさせていただいているのですが、こんしゅうから note の記事が大量に投下されていたのでいくつか拝見しに行きました。
テーマは面白く観点も中島さんぽいとは思ったのですが、どうも「エーアイが書いた感」が拭えず、普段からのメルマガ読者として複雑な気持ちになりました。
十年ほど購読しています。
この複雑な気持ちというか、気持ち悪さというかを、うまく言葉にできないのですが、一つあると思ったのは、「中島さんが主語になっていない」ということです。
という質問をいただきました。
Note の記事は百パーセント、エーアイに書かせているので、私の気持ちが入っていないのは当然です。
現在、実験的に行なっているのは、エーアイに書かせた紹介記事は Note に置き、私の意見をこのメルマガで書く、というアプローチです。
どこからどこまでが私の文章か、を明確にするためにそんなアプローチを試みています。
最後のご質問です。
こんしゅう号で、エーアイエージェントを使いこなすシニアエンジニアが五人チームを上回るうえ、そのシニア自身にはエーアイの間違いを見抜けるだけの経験が必要だというお話が印象に残りました。
私自身、実装のかなりの部分をエーアイエージェントに任せているため、エーアイの利用が進むほど、実装の妥当性を自分で判断するための経験をどのように積めばよいのかが気になりました。
中島様は、エーアイの出力を適切に判断できる力を身につけるうえで、今後も一定量の実装経験そのものが必要だとお考えでしょうか。
それとも、エーアイが書いたものを検証し、設計や不具合の原因を考える経験を積むことで、その判断力を身につけられるとお考えでしょうか。
という質問ですね。
私自身も色々と試しているところですが、設計の段階では「何が大切か」をエルエルエムに伝えることが重要で、作ったものに関しては、品質を上げるための様々な工夫をしているところです。
他のエーアイモデルにコードレビューをさせる、テストを充実させてバグを未然に発見する、ハーネスでエルエルエムができることに制限をかけて安定させる、などです。
オープンソースで開発している Mulmo Claude / Mulmo Terminal は、そんな仕組みの塊なので、エルエルエムに参照させながら、勉強するのも悪くないと思います。
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。